[Music]
are you afraid of dying no
not at all
do you think you go somewhere
no
the one thing i can't understand i can't
grasp my mind around
i feel when you dive is just nothing
it's like when you're asleep and you're
not dreaming but i can't imagine
nothingness
lasting forever
what's the secret to a long life
i have no idea
to me it's still been a short life i
hope it goes on a lot longer i i think
being interested in what you're doing
um i know my father the poor guy
it was during the depression and he was
out of work most of the time
so his life was shorter
and it was because there was nothing
really that he was doing that could
interest him
but i think if you do
what really excites you it just keeps
you going as as long as possible how do
you keep the creative juices flowing to
keep creating work over the years i'm
doing what i enjoy doing
it's like other men like to play golf so
they play golf every chance they can so
you don't say to him how come you're
playing golf today you played last week
was the same with me to me
it's an exciting life
and when you do something that you know
the fans seem to enjoy that gives you
such satisfaction you don't want to stop
one thing you change about the world
what would it change
i'd make people not hate each other
because of their religion because of
their nationality because of any stupid
reason if we could abolish hatred we
live on this gorgeous planet there's a
character i wrote called the silver
surfer and i always had him making those
kind of remarks philosophical things
about he was from another world and he
said why don't we realize we're on a
planet that gives us everything food
beautiful weather sun everything
why don't we enjoy it why do we spend
time fighting and hating each other i
loved riding a silver surfer you are
basically a child at heart aren't you
yes yeah how did you get into comic
books
purely by accident i guess when i went
to work for marvel which then was called
timely comics
it was the very early 1940s
and
i had a job there as i was sort of the
office boy
i
in fact i didn't know i was going to be
doing comics it was a publishing company
and i heard they wanted they had there
was a job open for an assistant
now they also published men's magazines
movie magazines sport magazines and they
had a little comic book section
somewhere that i i was hardly aware of
so i applied for the job and i found out
it was for the comic book department
and there were only two people running
that department joe simon and jack kirby
and i started working for them i filled
the inkwells in those days people used
ink
i erased pages
and i went down and got them sandwiches
for lunch and stuff like that
after a while they left
and it had been a three-man department
and now i was the only man left and i
was about 17 and a half and the uh
publisher came over to me and said do
you think you can keep things going till
i find a grown-up you know
to run the place
well when you're 17 and a half what do
you know i said sure i can handle it
so i guess i did because he never found
that grown up and i was there ever since
which character which story
makes you was the first one where you
felt i'm on to something here
i'm not just writing fight scenes for a
dollar i got something here i guess the
first fantastic four story
because that was the first one that i
wrote
the way i really wanted to write it
up until then i was just trying to
please my publisher
and he had no respect at all for the
readers he thought they were either very
very young children or
semi-literate adults and he felt just
give them action that's all they want
so with the fantastic four i tried to do
some
character development
i gave each one his own distinctive way
of speaking things like that
and
that was not what my publisher had
wanted and the reason i did it was i was
thinking of quitting at that point and
my wife said to me before you quit why
don't you get it out of your system do
one story the way you'd want to
the worst that could happen he'll fire
you but you want to quit anyway
so that's when i did the fantastic four
and strangely enough
it sold very well so my publisher came
in and he said hey how about doing some
more superheroes the one thing i would
suggest is
it's important to please the person
you're working for and so forth
but you've got to please yourself you've
got to do something you think is
terrific
something you would love to see if
somebody else had done it
if you have an idea
that you genuinely think is good
don't let some idiot talk you out of it
now
that doesn't mean that every wild notion
you come up with is going to be genius
but if there is something that you feel
is good something you want to do
something that means something to you
try to do it
because i think you can only do your
best work if you're doing what you want
to do and if you're doing it the way you
think it should be done
and if you can take pride in it after
you've done it no matter what it is you
can look at it and say i did that and i
think it's pretty damn good
that's a great feeling so don't let
idiots
talk you
out of something that you think is good
by the same token that doesn't mean
every single thing you think is gonna is
good it's gonna be win a prize
gotta have a little judgment there i've
had other things that i thought were
good that didn't work but my publisher
came to me and he said stan i want you
to come up with another superhero
so i said okay i went home and
and i saw a fly crawling on the wall
and i said hey if i could get a
superhero that could stick to walls and
crawl on them
man that would be cool
so i thought that was good now i needed
a name
so let's see fly man
mosquito man
i got down to spiderman
spiderman it just sounded dramatic
so okay i had my hero i had his power
his name
and then i figured just for fun
i'm gonna give him personal problems
then i thought i'd make him a teenager
because there were no teenage
superheroes that i knew of at the time
so armed with all that wonderful
material those great ideas i ran into my
publisher's office and i told them
this was the reaction he gave me
stan that is the worst idea i have ever
heard
first of all people hate spiders
so you can't call a hero spiderman
you want him to be a teenager
teenagers can only be sidekicks
and you want him to have personal
problems
stan don't you know what a superhero is
they don't have personal problems
well i left the office
disappointed but obviously a much wiser
man
and i couldn't get spider-man out of my
system
so we were about to kill a magazine i
think it was called amazing fantasy
just to get it out of my system
i put spider-man in amazing fantasy
feature them on the cover
forgot about it a month later all the
sales figures came in
my publisher came racing into my office
stan stan you remember that character we
both loved so much spider-man
do them as a series are there some
real-life modern-day heroes in your mind
who in the world do you admire a lot
there are a lot of servicemen that i
meet when i go to conventions and we
talk
people in service in this country i have
great admiration for i have great
admiration for people who do anything
well i don't care whether it's writing
or drawing a comic book or making
neckties or
athletics or any anybody who does
something well i admire tell me about uh
meet and meet and stand well first of
all i i love what you said and let me
just say to the family
and to the legions of fans
that i remember stan as a true gentleman
who had this glint in his eye he's a
creative genius he thought outside the
box he created a whole universe that
changed the lives of many people mine
included stan god bless you you're one
of the greats
hi heroes this is stan lee coming at you
i want you to know
marvel
has always been and always will be a
reflection of the world right outside
our window
that world may change and evolve
but the one thing that will never change
is the way we tell our stories of
heroism
those stories have room for everyone
regardless of their race
gender religion or color of their skin
the only things we don't have room for
are hatred intolerance and bigotry that
man next to you he's your brother
that woman over there she's your sister
and that kid walking by hey who knows he
may have the proportionate strength of a
spider we're all part of one big family
the human family and you you're part of
that family you're part of the marvel
universe that moves ever upward and
onward to greater glory
[Music]
you